وقالت حركه حماس انها تصدي كتائب القسام
للعدوان الاسرائيلي بصواريخ المضاده
للطائرات اربك جيش الاحتلال ومستوطنين وان
المقاومه تواصل القيامه بواجبها بدفاع عن
الشعب الفلسطيني وستبقى درعه وسيفه
ان المقاومه تملك حقا قتال بكل الاساليب
ردا على عدوان الاحتلال وجرائمه بجانبها
قالت حركه الجهاد الاسلامي ان المقاومه لن
تتردد في اتخاذ قرار المواجهه وانها لم
تفرط بالدم الفلسطيني في جنين والقدس
تحول الى مراسلين من غزه ينضم الينا وائل
الدحدوح ومن القدس الياس كرام وقال نبدا
معك هل من تطورات منذ توقفت القصف من
تتوقف القصف
[موسيقى]
جلال لا يوجد تطورات تذكر او بمعنى اخر
خرق لي الاجواء التي سادت منذ ساعات
الصباح اجواء محافظات قطاع غزه بمعنى ان
الاجواء ما تزال في حال الترقب هناك ترقب
حذر وهناك بعض التحسب من امكانيه همم يعني
وقوع شيء ما لا سيما مع استمرار التحليق
المكثف لطائرات الاستطلاع المسيره
الاسرائيليه في مختلف محافظات قطاع غزه
ولكن القناعه السائده والراسخه لدى
المتابعين والعارفين بالشان الفلسطيني فان
فانه يمكن القول بان هذه الموجه من
التصعيد بالفعل همم يعني انتهت واصبحت
خلفنا تماما على اعتبار ان ما جرى من
تطورات لم يخرج عن السياق المعتاد في مثل
هذا النوع من موجات التصعيد بمعنى بانها
ربما ترسيخ عملي لقواعد اشتباك التي ظلت
سائده طوال سنوات مضت بين قطاع غزه
واسرائيل باستثناء بطبيعه الحال الموجات
الكبيره
والحروب التي تشنها اسرائيل على قطاع غزه
وما جرى بان همم يعني فصائل المقاومه
الفلسطينيه اطلقت صاروخين باتجاه منطقه
ربما تعتبر تجاوزا ولو قليلا للقواعد
السائده بمعنى انها اتجهت باتجاه مدينه
عسقلان وهي ابعد قليلا من الغلاف
وقوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي بالتاكيد قامت
الطائرات
بتنفيذ غارات اسرائيليه استهدفت موقعا
عسكريا في منطقه المغازي همم وسط قطاع غزه
وكان لافتا حسب شهود العيال
والمراقبين بان همم الطائرات الاسرائيليه
دكت هذا الموقع بعد عدد كبير تجاوز 10
صواريخ همم من الصواريخ شديده الانفجار
همم ومنطقه الوسطى وحتى منطقه مدينه غزه
سمعت اصوات الانفجارات جراء هذه الصواريخ
وهو الموقع الذي تعرض جلال الى عديد
المرات بالقصف الاسرائيلي كل ما كان هناك
مناوشات بين قطاع غزه او بين المقاومه
الفلسطينيه وجيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
يتعرض هذا الموقع الى عدد كبير ولافت من
الصواريخ في ذات المنطقه وكانه يريد ان
يستهدف اشياء تحت الارض في هذا الموقع على
الرغم من عدم وقوع اصابات في كافه الغارات
التي نفذت اليوم وفي مرات سابقه باعتبار
ان هذه المواقع عاده ما تكون مخلاف حركه
حماس الجهاد الاسلامي صدروا بيانات عقبوا
على هذا الاطلاق وكان لافتا ايضا اطلاق
صواريخ ارض جو باتجاه الطائرات مغيره على
قطاع غزه وهي من المرات القليله التي
شهدناها في الاونه الاخيره هناك ايضا
اليوم مسيرات سوف تنطلق من كافه المساجد
في محافظات القطاع الخمس دعت لها حماس
والجهاد الاسلامي وبالتالي نحن امام
الهدوء الحذر الذي مازال يسود محافظه
القطع للجيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي اعلنها
وزير الدفاع يوقلان